this program is brought to you by Emory
University
we got to the first
for from a patient's that was prevent
presenting with priate symptoms in
january 1983 and we put in a culture in
the lab and got the first sign of virus
replication in the culture a few weeks
later mid mid January 1983 so that was
the first detection net set of the
retrovirus in the culture and obviously
it was still a lot of work to be done to
show the link between the virus and the
disease itself of course later on I mean
the first detection was in 1983 then we
had to characterize a virus both
biological properties of the virus but
also the replication cycle and the first
thing that was done indeed before
because before developing antiretroviral
treatment was a development of
diagnostic tests and the diagnostic
tests were available as soon as June
July 1985 they were commercialized later
on the first drug that was showing some
effect let's say in patient was easy T
that was at the end of the 1980s and
unfortunately as 80 or so was already
showing to prevent mother-to-child
transmission in 1994 we had to wait 1996
to have the combination of treatment
that we know today as heart and this
combination of treatment is as you know
reducing the mortality of HIV infected
patient by more than a eighty-five
ninety percent
you
the preceding program is
Murray university